Salut ! Alors comme je vous ai expliqué il y a un petit peu plus d'une semaine dans la vidéo où j'annonçais les vidéos qu'on allait faire cet été,
nous arrivons donc à la série de 32 énigmes.
Durant 32 jours, je vous donne une énigme chaque jour,
avec la solution le lendemain
et la nouvelle énigme bien sûr !
Je tourne tout ça ici, depuis le YouTube Space à Paris.
Et on a crée un petit code de luminosité.
Quand il fait nuit, c'est que je donne la solution d'une énigme de la veille.
Et quand il fait jour, c'est que je vous donne la nouvelle énigme.
Qu'est-ce que je vais faire moi, durant ces 32 jours?
Déjà je vais prendre un peu de vacances, je vais préparer de la matière aussi pour la reprise de fin août,
pour pouvoir attaquer sereinement la dernière ligne droite du défi, de faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Merci à vous tous qui êtes là depuis le départ, ou depuis hier
peu importe, merci à tous.
Merci aussi à tous ceux qui sous-titrent les vidéos pour les rendre accessibles aux malentendants
ça c'est vraiment génial !
Comme d'habitude je continuerai à lire tous vos commentaires,
sauf que là évidemment je ne vais pas répondre à tout le monde, mais en tout cas sachez qu'avec l'application que j'ai sur le téléphone
je lis toujours tous les commentaires.
J'espère donc que cette série spécialement faite pour l'été dans un format plus léger, un espèce de jeu quotidien vous plaira.
J'espère que vous prendrez beaucoup de plaisir à faire ces énigmes là.
Et c'est parti pour la première.
On se retrouve donc dans ce magnifique studio du YouTube Space pour la première énigme de cet été.
Ca vous laisse 24H pour trouver, des fois ce sera beaucoup trop, des fois ce sera beaucoup trop court.
Essayez de ne pas chercher la solution sur Internet, regardez plutôt la solution dans la vidéo que je fais le lendemain.
Comme ça vous avez en meme temps accès à la nouvelle énigme.
Première énigme, plutôt tranquille:
Imaginez une voiture qui vient de se garer à cet emplacement là.
Précisément.
La seule question que j'ai à vous poser, est quel est le numéro de sa place de parking ?
Allez-y, cherchez, essayez de trouver. Vous pouvez vous la refaire sur un petit bout de papier pour l'emmener avec vous ou pour essayer de le faire à d'autres personnes en même temps.
Evidemment vous pouvez en parler dans les commentaires de la vidéo,
mais si vous voulez qu'on fasse vraiment ce jeu là durant quelques jours,
ne mettez pas la réponse dans les commentaires.
Laissez plutôt les autres chercher, et par contre mettez que vous vous l'avez trouvé, avec votre temps de réflexion,
histoire que l'on puisse suivre tout ça et surtout dès que vous avez trouvé la bonne réponse, mettez un POUCE EN L'AIR !
Ce qui permettra de voir pour chaque vidéo, quel est le pourcentage de gens qui ont trouvé par rapport au nombre de vues.
Profitez du soleil, passez un très bel été. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !